the price of a part of buying a home can
be daunting for many Americans but in
parts of Italy they are practically
giving houses away Seth Doane traveled
to Sicily where some bargain-hunting
homebuyers are finding a deal with a
catch its house hunting for the brave
the condition is it's like you can see
it's not the best one but just eNOS
perco who's from Poland came hoping to
find a hidden gem there is a lot of
original elements like fluorine chlorine
is beautiful yes and well some of the
decorations or details may not be ideal
at least here the price is right in
Moose omelly a hilltop town in the heart
of Sicily houses are selling for 1 euro
even with an unfavorable exchange rate
that's about a dollar 20 so far the city
has helped sell about a hundred of these
houses I'd want to go to this house a
castle and they have a hundred boar to
sell we have this house for the goal is
to revive the rundown center of this
remote towns that's another one your
house this is a one year the 22 is a one
year old house and another one totemic
really manages the program the house
become your so you can do everything you
want with your house you can sell your
house you can make a shop you can make
BMB hotel the fine print you have to fix
it up within three years if someone owns
this house why would this person sell it
for a euro because in Italy if you have
more than one house you have to pay a
lot of taxes so they prefer to sell
houses and not pay taxes the houses need
a lot of work more than many existing
homeowners want or can afford to do but
it's a different calculation for
foreigners the woman who bought this
house lives in the San Francisco area
and she's become a sort of ambassador to
this place now a number of her friends
and family are buying here too
we reached some of them by video chat in
San Francisco
did you all think that you would be
homeowners in Sicily never in all rubia
Daniels convinced friends and family to
buy 13 homes in Musel Mellie what was
the pitch everybody they explained even
with about three thousand dollars in
closing costs and tens of thousands in
renovation work it's still a deal people
boo so Mellie is one of about a dozen
towns across Italy to test this out
nice house can we have a look and early
adopters have become role models
Nina Smiths and Bert Vaughn Bellingham
read about the program in Belgium and
about a year later live here I found a
lot of things in the house I recovered
them I cleaned them and I use them how
different does it look now from when you
first bought it it's impossible they
wound up paying a bit more for this
place which has a stunning view and did
almost all of the work themselves
there were nightmares of trying to
figure things out find something for
fixing stuff no no everything here and
everybody helps you panic they say
what's important here is the buongiorno
they hear from the neighbors the slower
pace and sense of community how do you
feel here
happy happy and relaxed yes this is life
it's a richer life at a much lower cost
for CBS this morning Saturday Seth Doane
Musso Melly Italy chef look at me to
call no I'm not where you find the time
to renovate it but I'm looking at the
pictures it's I would not want to live
there yeah
now here you want to renovate I do look
do it great like it